une réforme des retraites inspirée de ce
que vote la majorité de droits et du
centre du Sénat à chaque année c'est
plutôt déjà une victoire pour vous non
ça prouve que le Sénat avait bien
travaillé qu'on avait pris de l'avance
sur ce qu'on pouvait faire ce qu'il
fallait faire et je trouve positif que
le gouvernement on a commencé à penser
quand on a rencontré la première
ministre ce soit fondé sur le travail
réalisé par le Sénat qui reste une
référence et un peu la pierre angulaire
institutionnelle en ce moment finalement
la promesse d'Emmanuel Macron pendant la
campagne d'aller plutôt sur un âge à 65
ans a été abandonné on est sur peut-être
une réforme moins brutale selon vous
c'est une réforme qui est pragmatique
qui est prudente qui laisse la place
encore au dialogue parce que tout n'est
pas dans le texte beaucoup de choses
sont inspirées des rencontres que les
uns et les autres ont eu avec la
première ministre et Monsieur du soft
mais il reste encore la place au débat
pour perfectionner le dispositif et je
pense que ça sera l'occasion
au Parlement à l'Assemblée comme au
Sénat pour apporter des compléments
quelle modifications qu'elles
améliorations les sénateurs centrist
pourraient apporter à ce texte je pense
qu'il y a encore un peu de grains à
moudre comme on dit sur le travail des
seniors nous nous étions très
intéressés par la revendication portée
pour les seniors un bonus malus pour les
entreprises je crois qu'on a été entendu
mais on peut aller un peu plus loin avec
également une amélioration pour celles
et ceux qui travaillent qui ont déjà
leur point d'accord et en gros qui
travaillent pour pas grand chose puisque
je crois que c'est un 25% de revenus par
trimestre en plus etc donc on peut
retravailler un peu sur ce que chacun
peut attendre du travail qu'il réalisera
alors qu'il a même tous ces points donc
voilà c'est un exemple de ce qu'on peut
encore discuter sur l'emploi des seniors
Elisabeth borne a annoncé un index pour
les grandes entreprises pour montrer
qu'elle maintenaient leur Seigneur en
emploi et ce qu'il faut prévoir des
sanctions si et bien à licencier trop de
seniors par exemple je crois que c'est
prévu d'ores et déjà après il faut
rentrer dans le détail on va
s'apercevoir qu'il reste des
imperfections des niches des cas
particuliers c'est tout le travail
parlementaire pour justement essayer de
colmater ses brèches et puis d'améliorer
ce qui peut encore l'être si jamais le
payer est bloqué avec la mobilisation
sociale les manifestations les grèves
dans plusieurs secteurs est-ce qu'il
faudrait reculer sur notamment cet âge
de départ non je crois que la réforme
est indispensable c'est la raison pour
laquelle depuis déjà pas mal d'années
nous souhaitons l'idée d'une réforme on
voit bien que tous les 5 ans environ il
faut améliorer le dispositif c'est pas
un dispositif qui peut être
définitivement pérenne là ça va jusqu'en
2030 on sait ce qu'on peut gagner
jusqu'en 2030 après on sait pas bien
donc c'est normal qui est un horizon un
peu marqué une ligne et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle tous les 5 ans en
général il y a une réforme donc là on
fait quelque chose qui va
garantir le système et garantir les
Français jusqu'en 2030
[Musique]